los jueces se mostraron escépticos
frente al caso ruby way que como usted
lo mencionaba permite el aborto antes de
las 24 semanas de gestación
básicamente argumentan que no debería
ser la corte suprema de justicia la que
decida sobre el caso del aborto en eeuu
sino los funcionarios electos en cada
estado que sean los estados los que
definan esto y argumentaron también y
expresaron también la opinión de que
pues el derecho al aborto no está en la
constitución y que esto dificulta
entonces a las cortes inferiores de pues
ejercer esta ley de aplicar la
interpretar esta ley a nivel estatal así
que le cede entonces ese es el argumento
de los jueces conservadores el derecho a
los estados a definir el caso del aborto
que en el caso de misisipí la ley que
trata de impulsar misisipí sólo prohíbe
el aborto antes de las 15 después de las
15 semanas si hay malformación defecto o
alguna emergencia médica bueno cristóbal
y hablemos de cuando se conocería la
decisión y qué consecuencias tendría que
algunos estados o prohíban el aborto y
otros
exacto alrededor de junio o julio del
2022 se conocería la decisión y pues
esto abriría una caja de pandora dicen
muchos analistas porque entonces varios
estados tendrían entonces si en él se
aplica el caso del aborto poder definir
leyes tan polémicas como el tema del
matrimonio gay o el tema de el porte de
armas a nivel estatal y no federal
siguiendo el precedente y los
precedentes de la corte suprema de
justicia a nivel federal además lo que
argumentan muchos activistas con los que
estuvimos conversando aquí a las afueras
de la corte suprema que se manifestaron
es que pues esto llevaría a que mucha
gente trate de viajar a otros estados
para poder hacerse el aborto pero
solamente la gente con recursos podría
hacer esto los que no lo tengan tendrían
que simplemente seguir con un embarazo
no deseado